what is that this is tantalum which bit
and this bit here tantalum is another
element which has become more important
in recent years the importance of
tantalum is that it is used in making
capacitors in mobile phones capacitors
are the components that store up charge
in electricity and you can make really
small and effective capacitors from
tantalum so tantalum has gone from being
an element that is not widely exciting
to something that you find in every
mobile phone so this is a sample of
tantalum wire very high quality research
sample point two millimeters in diameter
tantalum haven't got a clue what is
useful